en multitudinarias protestas miles de
personas salieron a las calles de esta
panaker la capital del autoproclamada
República dearstage por un bloqueo al
corredor lachin la única vía que conecta
la disputada región de nagorno caravag
con Armenia
Este es el único camino que conecta
artage con el resto del mundo no solo
Armenia llegamos al resto del mundo a
través de Armenia las situaciones muy
grave pero la gente sin embargo intenta
aguantar
la autoproclamada República de astash se
encuentra ubicada en la frontera entre
azerbaiyán y Armenia pero es habitada
por una mayoría étnica Armenia Por lo
cual es territorio de disputa
internacional
el corredor la china ha sido bloqueada
durante casi dos semanas por
manifestantes azerbaellanos que
protestan en contra de las minas
ilegales de la zona Pero los dos países
entraron en una guerra en el otoño de
2020 por el control de la ruta Armenia
acusa a azerbaiyán de querer provocar
una crisis humanitaria
los habitantes de la zona ya empiezan a
sentir los estragos de casi dos semanas
de bloqueos
casas de medicamentos alimentos para
bebé pañales medicamentos para la
presión para adultos no podemos atender
a todos adecuadamente liberamos los
medicamentos en pequeñas cantidades
los bloqueos del corredor Vial han
aumentado el temor de una nueva guerra
en la región en septiembre de 2022 los
combates en la frontera entre ambos
países dejaron cerca de 300 muertos